et la tunisie toujours en difficulté
dans sa lutte contre le coc u19 malgré
l'accélération de sa campagne de
vaccination alors que le pays traverse
une crise politique majeure les
autorités sanitaires penta convaincre la
population de se faire vacciner pour
autant le pays a reçu de nombreux dons
de ses hommes les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis bassin chebbi une
situation épidémique encore volatile
illustré par un taux de positivité qui
repart à la hausse après des semaines de
stabilité la tunisie peine à sortir de
cette quatrième vague de coronavirus les
tunisiens demeurent toujours trop peu
nombreux à se rendre dans les centres de
vaccination malgré un taux important
d'inscriptions sur la plateforme et vax
à peine 34 % de la population s'est vu
inoculer une première dose de sérum anti
co-lead malgré les dons de vaccins qui
continuent d'affluer des quatre coins du
globe c'est une situation que déplorent
les autorités qui craignent ne pas
pouvoir atteindre limitée collective
alors qu'une nouvelle vague semble se
dessiner dans le pays et mercredi à deux
avions en provenance d'alger et de ryad
ont atterri à tunis avec à leur bord pas
moins de 800 mille doses de sérum du
matériel médical et des respirateurs de
quoi venir soulager les hôpitaux aux
tunisiens au bord de l'implosion face à
l'exaspération de la population et à la
baisse des contaminations
le gouvernement avait décidé d'assouplir
les mesures de restriction comme le
couvre-feu qui était passée de 22 heures
à minuit et des mesures qui semblent
hélas avoir eu un effet négatif encore
l'augmentation des contaminations le
ministère de la santé a fait état de
trois mille cinq cent cinquante deux
nouveaux cas de contamination pour la
journée du 24 août soit un taux de
positivité de 23 avec 2 73 % contre 21
22 38% le 15 août dernier craignant une
nouvelle vague meurtrière le comité
scientifique tunisien envisagerait même
de rendre obligatoire le pass and i
terre à l'entrée des espaces publics
afin d'inciter les tunisiens se faire
vacciner dans les plus brefs délais